a businessman 20 years ago wasn't famous
the Internet is grossly underestimated
[Music]
thank you my friend not good not bad
right
this is the head office yeah yes yes yes
alter yes public speaker yes your own
speaker that's the best of the whole
bunch you know I think this is being an
entrepreneur but yeah man if you told
the 20 you know 42 if you told the 24
year old version of me yeah that I would
be getting paid millions of dollars to
be the face of a sneaker I would have
lacked I would have laughed you I would
have laughed you out of my liquor store
yeah I think it's possible because the
Internet is unbelievably underestimated
yeah it this is a very important point I
do not believe anybody including its
biggest advocates yeah are actually
giving the respect to the fact that the
internet became real life and real life
became secondary yeah and that's like
uncomfortable for some and what I mean
by real life of course I don't mean it
like that
what I mean by that is attention
attention
yeah is the absolute asset of the world
well why does FIFA you know make an
unbelievable amount of money during the
World Cup because every four years the
entire world pays attention to something
and if somebody's wearing a sponsorship
logo if there's commercials during it if
there's events in eight towns in Russia
there's money to be made
without that attention if nobody was
watching
Christiano Ronaldo would not make a
hundred million dollars a year plus
people used to watch airplane pilots and
astronauts and they made more money now
they don't they make less yeah today we
look at Fame in many different ways I am
now pseudo famous which makes me laugh
saying it a business man 20 years ago
wasn't famous the Internet is grossly
underestimated for me as a person
how it started is how it is today from
the lemonade stand to this sneaker is
it's very simple I've always been a
Salesman and a businessman it's now
called an entrepreneur I always sold
stuff lemonade
raking leaves shoveling snow I was in
Edison New Jersey I was born in Belarus
in the former Soviet Union I emigrated
to the US lived in Queens
then in Jersey very humbly we grew up
you know
you know we didn't have any money and
then we became a middle-class family
upper-middle class but my parents spent
money like we were still poor I was a
real hustler even before that selling
pencils and lollipops and lemonade and
gambling and whatever the [ __ ] it took
you know like you know I was a hustler
and I was an entrepreneur and a business
kid when it wasn't that wasn't cool it
was bad
grab my report card d-roc you know I
know they could have grades in different
ways in Europe in the US but in America
a is good at is bad and and sorry about
that and and you know ABCDEF you can see
here I was a terrible terrible student
here but besides gratitude and guilt no
question do I want to stick it in the
mouth stick it right to the parents and
teachers who slept on me who didn't
understand what I was about
who talked [ __ ] who I now enjoy the
feeling of them looking and saying hmm I
was wrong
no it's not like I want to razz them or
make them upset all I want them to say
was I was wrong yeah not I want to hurt
their feelings or make fun of them I
just want them to say I was wrong I
didn't see what he had he was right I
was right where the world was going they
were wrong mm-hmm when you get [ __ ] on
from five to 15 and when you don't have
a lot of stuff and when the world's
telling you you're losing and when your
parents do a good job and don't hand you
everything you [ __ ] never lose that
hunger I'm hungry or right this second
then I've ever been in my [ __ ] life
yeah
and I have a lot more than I've ever had
100% my dad was an entrepreneur yeah
100% we came to America came to America
he worked for his great uncle's liquor
store eventually he bought it he was
entrepreneur through and through 100% my
dad is an entrepreneur it I could never
see my dad working for somebody he'd be
fired multiple times but so would I for
different reasons yes that is in our DNA
okay I'm very curious adversity yeah oh
it's adversities the road to success and
what do you mean explain to the people
watching when you're hungry you have to
hunt for food let me give you one of
your not adversities you I don't know
you I've know you for four minutes I can
tell you right now one of the things
that is not an adversity for you you're
a good looking dude you're good looking
good so that wasn't one of the things
that drives you that came natural to you
for a lot of boys like getting girls
because they're not pretty was a big
driver but other things could be
adversity for you that I'm fascinated by
that yeah right
being a short mail at adversity not
being good looking adversity being a bad
student adversity not having money
adversity like not making your Michael
Jordan who I hate hate because I'm a
Knicks fan
that's why Madison Square Garden is
right there Michael Jordan got cut from
his sophomore basketball team and went
on to become one of the great basketball
players of all time
Tom Brady who I hate late like hate why
cuz I'm a huge Jets fan Tom Brady went
on to become one of the best
quarterbacks of all time and he was the
backup quarterback in college yeah he
went in the sixth round people don't get
it adversity Messi let's use a little
football no short Messi is supposed to
be he's short now you know short he was
supposed to be before they started
injecting him with hormones that's at
verse video must be a hundred thousand
but that's one thing it's it's anything
yeah if you want to talk about success
success is predicated on effort and
ambition where does that come from it
comes from adversity let me give you a
weird adversity your mom and dad were
super successful and everybody who's
looking at you you're growing up and
your own rough rich and everybody's
[ __ ] on you because they're saying
no matter what you do your mommy and
daddy gave it to you that [ __ ] aspire
for people some people run away other
people run into it okay what got them
huge to prove to their dad that they
could be bigger than them I've two
children one of them might run away mom
might say [ __ ] that's a big mountain
[ __ ] you
Alexis stop they're gonna say [ __ ] you
Gary dad I'm gonna climb your Mountain
and be bigger than you impact more
people than you and make more money
it's adversity adversity look there's a
lot of things but let me tell you one
thing that I think we will all agree on
you have to be great at your craft right
to be successful you have to be good
well why are you putting in all those
hours you're either putting it in
because you love it passion or adversity
it's Star Wars good and bad rules for
your success yes self-awareness number
one if you don't know who you are you're
finished I could wish to be somebody why
do you think so few people did I talk
about it I just helped you just asked me
what are my top five things for success
my first answer was self-awareness
I think I'm helping I think my answers
and my nuance in the marketplace right
now is predicated on I'm talking about
different things than the entrepreneurs
that made it before me yes I talk about
hard work you know yes I talk about
discipline and other things but I talk a
lot more about this mindset was it yeah
it matters this is the operating system
people spend more time updating their
phones than updating their minds this is
it is your perspective right are you
happy are you putting yourself in a
position to succeed there's only one way
you can be a workaholic you love it
how many hours do you work edit hmm 15
15 15 bit hard do you keep derive focus
in if you work 15 hours a day cuz I cuz
I love it cuz I'm in my you know I don't
know music well but like the crescendo
Mamluk ting you know like that
you know I don't know what I'm doing
right now but like it's a color is that
called a crescendo what is a crescendo
nonetheless you know the perfect pitch
perfect pitch right team I feel like I'm
living my life with a perfect pitch like
I'm doing exactly what I should be doing
here's what I could say yeah I don't
know if you know when you when you've
hit it or how do you know when you found
it yeah but I think you know when you
don't have it right I think if you ask
somebody are you in a perfect spot right
now a lot of people can answer no yeah
you know and and you know I I don't know
look I'll tell you something else I keep
things unbelievably basic to me
happiness is about doing what you want
to be doing too many people focus on the
money the things that come along with it
I think you have to focus on the process
you have to you have to focus on do you
like it ix
from 7 a.m. to 11 p.m. do you love it me
too
why yes you keep the venoms also alive
this communication together yeah cuz
things change
yeah things change and things change my
son is now more into sports in the last
year I want to spend more time with him
yes but I play through extremism what's
working for me now is on the weekends
I'm all out with the family and I'm
taking for sure for sure and that's
already a hundred days a year that's
already a third of my time
no not me I I understand why people
should could like to not me Monday
through Thursday see ya and that's real
Gary time midday Friday night Friday
night it really Friday night and the
weekend it's them time and then seven
weeks seven weeks
besides the weekends vacation - in
December - in August for sure so now all
of a sudden you're taking 35 days you're
taking fifth a hundred days I'm taking
130 I'm taking 1/3 of my time minimum
Lee with the family now by the way some
people want to spend 80% of time than
with family mazelTov you do you you can
if you're success correct for me I want
to see this through what does that mean
we all know a lot about ourselves that
we never say out loud every one of us
and I'm looking at all of us right now
forget about everybody behind camera
there are three four things we know
about ourselves that we have never said
to anybody only to ourselves in our own
mind about us you want an exclusive you
know I think I'll give you an example
I'm think I'm unbelievably selfless the
reason people like me is I do so much
good but it's because I'm selfish
and nobody wants to say they're selfish
like but I am because I can't function
if I'm not happy how can I do anything
good for my family or my community
unless I'm happy you know why I'm
bringing so much value cuz I'm happier
than most people you know why because I
don't give a [ __ ] what people think
about me I think I didn't do anything I
think my parents and my circumstance did
that yeah it's why I also don't have a I
have an ego but an ego for my parents
and for America when I think about I'm
cool I think it means the Internet
America and my parents one I'm the
product I think a lot of people say to
me when I get to know me they like
you're humble you're not a dick actually
I like you you're nice whoa you're
humble because like you know I have a
lot of energy I don't think anybody
watching right now for the first time
thinks I'm humble it takes a little
while but there's only one reason I'm
humble I don't want I don't want to be
humble I'm only humble because it's the
truth I'm succeeding a lot more to do
with America the Internet and my parents
than I am with like oh I did this I'm
the product vaynermedia that's me my
kids
that will be me and my wife right that's
I'm the operator I'm very proud about
vaynermedia 800-plus London New York LA
Chattanooga Tennessee soon to be
Singapore I'm proud of that but me
having 3.5 million followers on
Instagram people saying I walk on water
and I'm this guy the visitor death
that's Sasha and tomorrow Vaynerchuk
that's being an immigrant from the
Soviet Union to America that's America
having a system where an immigrant can
do that that's the Internet
coming along at the right time 100,000
percent so I'm grateful I'm driven by
gratitude I understand my perspective
yes nanners started in 2009 may of 2009
it really started in September 2011
because the first two years I was still
wine I was writing crush it I didn't
want to do client services but then I
went all-in in 2011 in September and and
it's been an amazingly fun seven years
we went we went from 40 to 800 people in
seven years six and a half years listen
I'm an operator I was 31 years old
before I started my first wine video I
was 35 years old before I made one piece
of business content ever so I was a
businessman before I was a personality
and I think a lot of people who watch
forget that they see Gary Vee I think
Gary knows that's right I'm Gary
Vaynerchuk who's the producer and
strategist behind Gary B
then people see you oh I always don't
mind if people are confused by me if
they're confused by it being Gary me if
they're confused that I'm a motivational
speaker if they're confused that my
parents hand it to me they don't know
the details cuz they're busy and they
shouldn't read the story they don't they
hear my story I built my dad's business
from three to sixty million and they
hear it as my dad gave me three million
dollars and it's not only is it not the
case it was a three million dollar
business doing 30 hundred thousand and
profit but I built it for him I left my
business at 34 years old when we started
this that I built to a huge company with
no equity my dad owns wine library
ecommerce email being a Salesman on the
floor building an organization building
a great palette I was right about
Australian Spanish and you know New
Zealand wines being a practitioner with
all the experience that patience and
self-awareness patience and
self-awareness yeah by being patient not
wanting it now now the biggest the
single biggest reason most of the
entrepreneurs of this generation will
fail is because I'm fast yeah that's it
that's right
if you're if you're a football proper
football entrepreneur and you want it
too fast let me tell you what you do you
DM four three three yeah and you spam it
right
hey for Thursday post my video hey I'm
selling the soccer ball football ball
excuse me please put it up hey four
thirty I want to do an event with you
spam yeah when you're patient you DM
four three three and you say hey four
three three I love your content I'm in
the football space too I'd like to do
something great for you when you're
patient you give when you're impatient
you try to take and that is the
fundamental breaking point of today's
environment for you you know why yeah
because we live in a world now that
everybody looks at their Instagram feed
and they see all it's all FOMO it's all
they see their friends in Ibiza with
champagne and pretty girls and they're
like [ __ ] if I can make some more money
real fast I can go to Ibiza next year
and I can be with that champagne and
pretty girl yeah stupid that's the word
I don't like I don't like using stupid
it's stupid it's doing many things wrong
number one you're letting somebody else
dictate you yeah you're worried about
your friend Charles the [ __ ] does your
friend Charles have to do with you got
it it's all about impatience so patience
is an incredibly important pillar work
very hard each and every day a lot if
you want very big things you don't know
in hindsight because I have empathy for
people and I was very good at
understanding what people were gonna do
I understand that people are value time
so when I see a new technology that will
save them time hey Alexa when does
England play in the World Cup
thanks Alexa that was faster for me to
figure out what time England plays then
looking at the phone right I if I grit
right first of all already took where is
my see perfect actually where is my
phone so already it's charging Oh
actually I put it here already think
about how much fat this actually really
happened it took me longer to find my
phone before I went to es got it so why
am i betting on voice why am i betting
on voice I'm betting on voice because
it's faster hey Alexa what team did
Christiano Ronaldo sign with Alexa stop
that's faster that's faster than me
going to the phone so why am i now
investing and being the best at that
because I know in 2026 right in eight
years when all of you realize how much
better that is than this it's going to
matter yeah that's why I made the right
choices because I only care about one
thing one one thing the end customer not
me I care about my customer more than I
care about myself people tell me they
care about the end consumer they tell
you to tell you but they don't act it
the [ __ ] am i doing this interview for
yeah you do all of this because I bring
value I know it's gonna bring you value
yes I'll get some awareness for my
sneaker cool but guess what not a good
use of my 30 minutes I know that I'm
gonna change one kid's mind in this
video for sure maybe six yeah but I know
that you're gonna take this interview
and leverage it to get other people as
guests so now I'm bringing value I know
I know I know I know so I don't care
what people say I tell I tell my
audience all the time don't listen to
what I'm saying
watch what I'm doing do and do it that
is the best way to get value out of Gary
Vee is to watch what he's doing not what
he's saying
doing this and inspiration
Oh entrepreneurial start I hate that
people think I'm a motivational or
inspirational figure let me phrase
that's not there it's very nice but it's
like a byproduct of being a good person
and a good entrepreneur and I think
because I'm so successful at producing
content for the internet right now and
because I'm genuinely positive and
excited and motivated that some people
have me in that bucket and because
Instagram right now is the place where
attention is and because of the limited
nature of the one-minute video and a
picture I'm definitely more motivational
on that platform than I am on my podcast
on my LinkedIn on my and definitely in
my real life as an operating CEO you
know what I mean it's a part of my
personality it's the it's you know what
it's the mashed potatoes it is
absolutely not the steak or the lobster
you know it's not the it's not the green
beans
it's the mashed potatoes I understand
that but the motivational means the
mashed potatoes the entrepreneurial
operating executive is the stake in the
lobster I want to be the single most
admired entrepreneur of this generation
now in a world of you know incredible
founders like Bezos or Zuckerberg I
don't think I'll achieve the most money
but I I think I will impact emotionally
the most entrepreneurs and I have a
funny feeling that will get me more
people to my funeral
then Marc or Jeff will get ya or Elon I
really believe that
very much more busy with the people I'm
in the trenches because it's where I
come from I come from the dirt yeah even
though I'm striving for the clouds I
come from the dirt for me just a recap
for the road to success yes
self-awareness yeah
empathy yeah you have to have empathy
for your people you have to I mean you
know how much I love d-roc who films me
that's the first time I've ever seen him
drop his camera and it dropped on your
guy you know how did you want you know
you didn't get that even get to see the
angle I was watching him while we were
been doing this interview he was upset
for five minutes he's still upset you
know you have to have empathy do you
care about other people I think that's
how you become consumer-centric
I care more about my customer than
myself I care about my employees I care
about my employees first my customer
second and me third and honestly
actually it's not even true employees
customers the company Vayner media right
Wine Library do you know many times I've
paid people a severance from my bank
account personally not from the
companies because I thought that I was
doing the wrong thing by the company and
I wanted to do something for my former
employee it came out of my pocket most
people would've ursa me they want all
the money the only reason they have
employees or a company is for their
personal money I'm not so I think
empathy self-awareness empathy work
ethic I hate that so many people in the
liberal world and I'm very socially
liberal but my socially liberal friends
take it too far
work matters there's nobody who's gonna
beat me in Europe who works twenty five
hours a week
[ __ ] you know shot you can't beat me if
I work one day more than you work in a
week for sure now you may say you're
beating me in life because you're happy
cool that's fine that's a different
conversation yeah but you're not gonna
build a bigger [ __ ] business than me
and so I think work ethic matters for
you happiness happiness is this is what
happiness is based around use happiness
is everything it's bigger than the road
of success happiness
the [ __ ] North Star of life you know
for me when you're self-aware you're
already happy because if you really know
your the biggest reason people are
percent my friend and don't win is they
don't want to face who they are they
want to make pretend there's something
else it's why entrepreneurship so scary
being a footballer the field tells you
in black and white that you're not good
enough right
you know why entrepreneurship scary cuz
you just say you're an entrepreneur and
you are and we're accepting that right
now for now but if I said I'm a singer
you would say yeah but are you are you
gonna win Grammys if I said to you I'm a
basketball player you would say that's
nice but do you play in the NBA but when
people say they're an entrepreneur we
don't say yet but yeah are you do you
have a successful business or do you say
entrepreneur on your Instagram and you
sell for t-shirts a year on it when our
I think a good entrepreneur can't
breathe not being an entrepreneur and I
think 99% of the people right now that
say they're entrepreneurs are in it for
the money
I want to thank you for this time I
prefer a legend man thank you brother
makes you think you're having thanks for
having me
[Music]